حذر مسؤولون اوكرانيون من هجمات الروسيه
واسعه ياتي ذلك بعد ان دوت صفارات الانذار
في عموم اوكرانيا هذا وقالت السلطات
المحليه الاوكرانيه في خاركيز ان هجوم
استهدف منشات البنى التحتيه في المدينه
كما قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه لقواتها
صدت هجمات الروسيه باتجاه مناطق سيطراتها
في دنياك ولوجازك بالمقابل اشارت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه الى ان الطيران
الاوكراني نفذ خلال الساعات الاخيره نت 22
ضربه على مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه
وثلاث ضربات من منظمات صاروخيه
الى شبكه مراسلين من خرسون تامر الصمادي
وايضا تنضم الينا سلام خضر من دنياك تامر
ابدا معك اطلعنا على اخر التفاصيل فيما
يتعلق بالقصف الاخير
ااا نعم في هذه الاثناء جلال اعلنت
السلطات وانا انتظر هذا الهواء اعلنت
سلطات عن هجوم يستهدف مقاطعه ميكولاي
بالفعل الجنوبي البلاد والحديث عن البنيه
التحتيه هجوم روسي قصف روسي
وعمده المقاطعه تحدث خلال دقائق الاخيره
عن
توقعاته بان يكون هنالك هجوم مكثف على
نيكولا لايف على خير سون على اودسه على
عموم المقاطعات همم الاوكرانيه ويتوقع بان
يكون هنالك اكثر من 60 صاروخا روسيا قد
انطلقت بالفعل من بحر قزوين ومن البحر
الاسود في الحقيقه هذا الحديث المسؤول
الاوكراني جاء بعد دقائق ايضا من الانذار
الجوي الذي صدر في عموم اوكرانيا العديد
من المسؤولين همم الاوكرانيا يتحدثون في
هذه اللحظه عن توقعاتهم بان تكون هنالك
موجه واسعه كبيره من القصف الروسي
ويتحدثون عن صواريخ تنطلق كما قلت من
البحر الاسود والبحر قزوين
يرميكولايب الحديث عن خاركيب شرقا في هذه
الاثناء ايضا اعلنت السلطات هناك المحليه
عن استهداف البنيه التحتيه
بصواريخ ايضا روسيه وقالت بان الدفاعات
الجويه تعمل في هذه الاثناء في المقاطعه
التطورات في الحقيقه جلال متسارعه الجبهات
لا تتوقف وهي مستعره في الجنوب والشرق في
خرسون تحدثت قياده عمليات الجنوب خلال
الساعه الاخيره عن مقتل نحو 30 جنديا
روسيا في المواجهات المتواصله والقصف
والقصف المتبادل بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه على طول ضفتين هاردينيبر تحدثت
السلطات في المقابل هناك عن همم ان القصه
في طال
الروسي يطال قلب المدينه بالاضافه الى
القرى والبلدات الواقعه على خطوط التماس
حتى الرئيس الاوكراني في خطابه الليله
الماضيه يتحدث على وجه الخصوص عن خيرسون
وقال بان الساعات الاخيره
نفذ فيها الرؤوس اكثر من 19 هجوما على
المدينه وقال بان الاوضاع الانسانيه فيها
صعبه